amantha
hurry up dinner's on Javier oh you mean
you ordered focus oh my god you look
like a beautiful angel thanks ever dated
do alright I told you got to take that
medicine the doctor gave you that it's
not ours no he said your brother looking
at me snuffling all over the place he's
sick
whatever oh okay you had heard that guy
you just called me a loser no you need
to go through the doctor and get your
ears checked
honey you need to go to the doctor no no
no you need to get mom Oh mom overdue
mommy's running out of damn ass forget
it super fat you're so dumb I told you
from below oh jeez don't knock anymore I
always slow down what I have something
to tell you huh
I am something without you oh yeah but
I'll look in a way I'm kind of busy
that is awesome it is belly in salsa
oh it's important this is gonna talk
about cheese yeah I need $12 poppin I
think they're going to good you you must
leave now
Robert sounds like a great guy
I think we're gonna go at getting
through you know I can order postman
yeah I think you I on no no I I have so
much free to my bridge yeah
anything you guys want there's only
water air yeah oh we're just gonna go no
no no no why cuz I got you guys get yes
yes yes oh hang on
sign here Carrie oh this is Amanda ami
I'm gonna call the console you're on my
neighbor site you should cherish that I
want to be fine looks good
the couch am I gonna stay here in a
swimming pool love it
hey guys me amanda cerny thank you so
much for watching my attorneys guest and
liking and commenting i literally read
every single one of them so thank you
guys
teen journey is growing and I love in it
I want to involve you guys even more so
what I'm doing now is I'm taking
journeys get suggestion ideas that ain't
you just comment below any good ideas
that you have for me and if I decide to
choose your idea I will shout you out in
my next journey skate youtube video so
keep the comments coming and is enough
it could be you love you guys and I'll
see you next week thankful